phox rules analyst on for the National
Football League on Fox joining us here
on the show how are you Mike well I'm
just trying to figure out of the Idaho
potato bowl yes sir you actually when
you go into the store to buy your Idaho
potatoes do you stop at the big red box
and get a movie rental on your way out
you know Mike look look at you after
further revealing hi you got a tie these
you know ballgames together there's only
40 of them exactly after further review
I like it I'm great by the way terrific
let's get into it there's so much to get
into right now was that offensive pass
interference yesterday yes yes so then
watch said why why then why is it him to
me it should have been called on the
field but does it or did it rise to the
level of what they're looking for in
replay that would allow them to come in
look at it and put offensive pass
interference on the play answer no all
you have to do is follow all year long
what they've been doing and you see that
there is a different standard that they
use for replay and it's why the rule is
so screwed up but they're consistently
enforcing it let's think remember last
week Seattle San Francisco I mean my
gosh there was blatant pass interference
on San Francisco at the end of the game
in the end zone and it wasn't called and
it wasn't reviewed and that that that
play right there
had it been reviewed and had it been
called New Orleans would have had by the
way a first-round bye but it didn't rise
to that level that they felt it needed
to rise to and that's why it's a
lose/lose rule and they got to get rid
of it or figure out some way to to alter
it to where it makes more sense to
anybody I talked to Zimmer and Ziggy
Wolff before the game and they were
complaining to me about the rule and how
it hurt them so bad when they played
Green Bay their first time around well
they're probably not complaining now but
it's just a bad rule
again is they they played Greenbay let
me make sure I get this correct they
played in week two
it changed mic there's no question to
change because the way it was described
to all of us in the media during the
summer is that something like this call
and certainly like the one at the end of
the San Francisco Santa Seattle game was
absolutely going to be a flag installed
by replay and have you been able to suss
out what's changed well I mean to me it
like after week ten I mean they didn't
change anything I mean it was it was
almost absurd and and then it started to
tighten up a little bit and everybody
thought that okay once we get into the
playoffs or in week 16 and 17 they're
going to make calls that are either pass
interference or not pass interference
that's the way they're going to look at
it in replay but they haven't I mean you
you look at it and and you again you see
what happens in in San Francisco with
the Seattle game they're not going to
rely on replay to call the penalties
unless it's egregious unless it compares
to what happened in New Orleans a year
ago and and you know and honestly rich I
feel bad for our river on because I
don't even think he knows what the
standard is and and and when you put a
rule in that says that you want
something called one way on the field
and another way when you look at it and
replay I mean he was doomed to failure
right off the bat and and while they
hoped that they could survive through
the playoffs and not have him not have
this rule be a focus well guess what
what round one wild card it's a focus so
pretty hard to say to a coach if I'm al
River on and and I think he made a huge
mistake with his pool report when he
said there wasn't enough for a foul I
think he brought double controversy on
himself because it's offensive pass
interference Rudolph is big the defender
is smaller the push to the chest creates
separation and you know I think if
you're gonna be honest you got to say to
Sean Payton yep you know it was up at
your pass interference but not big
enough for me to stop the game and call
and you go are you kidding me I mean
this is this is how bad that rule is
Mike Pereira here on the Rich Eisen show
let's move to later in the afternoon the
clowny hit on went illegal we're not
yeah I do I think it is we were just
talking about it you know clowny and you
hate to go back to history but you've
probably talked about that you know he
knocked holes out of the game in week 16
last year with a helmet shot into the
sternum which cost him $40,000 and it
was called roughing the passer to mean a
different situation because winces
become a runner but he's going to the
ground almost of the ground and and he
hits him in the head and and I know it's
it's not technically late but when you
do go to the head and the interesting
thing when I watch that play over and
over again to me um slow motion replay
didn't make it look that bad but in real
time you can see him drop the head and
take a shot and you know I think it's
foul now certainly not going to keep
once in the game just because it was a
foul and if a foul got called but I do
think it's I do think it was a cheap
shot do you think that there is any sort
of stomach for the lack of better phrase
or desire in the NFL to institute what
college does no flag on the play but
guess what we're buzzing down that's a
helmet to helmet and we're gonna take a
look at it what do you think well I mean
you know my proposal which I which we
did in the you know the extinct AAF was
you let this guy judge get involved and
pass interference calls or no no calls
in the last five minutes of the game and
player safety at any time during the
game and and I still believe I'd like to
see that if your if your number one
priority is player safety if something
is missed like that and we see them a
lot where maybe it's a major facemask
that the guys don't see let let the sky
judge for a lack of a better term get
involved and put the penalty on or just
as important let them take it off I mean
if they call a blatant facemask and it
turns out he didn't have the mask it was
the collar in the front then take it off
but you know to me III think you make a
huge change I'd love
see him make a huge change and make it
make it be more about player safety than
it is pass interference because that
should be more important let's move
through the rest of the weekend with
Mike Pereira a former head of NFL refs
now lead rules analyst for the for the
NFL and college football on Fox and I
put the word lead in there just to
definitely get under Dean Blandy nose
skin right there Mike uh yeah I
appreciate that no make sure I tell him
well you just did a show with him right
you just you and you and Dean do know
crack nobody but he's not here he phoned
it in he pulled it in from we don't know
where he is he's been displaced look
aged Southern California we assumed he
might be you might be auditioning for
Dancing with the Stars antastic I love
it 656 to go in overtime Bill's driving
trying to get a field goal to win it
Kody Ford is called for an illegal
blindside block that absolutely hobbles
the bills final offensive possession of
the game what do you think of that call
I don't like to call I mean you know the
Dean and I on the show that we just did
when he called in you know he says
technically you know by the book that's
a foul and I and and come on I mean look
it I say screw the technicality of the
rule I mean that's not a way that this
rule was set up it's not the thing that
the committee wanted called is one of
these unintended consequences look the
rule says there has to be forcible
contact this rule was brought in to
really get rid of the deke leaders that
came on changes of possessions or punt
plays I mean the even lead with the
shoulder or the forearm or the helmet to
the head or neck area I mean again using
some common sense that you just there's
just not enough force it there's no
player at risk of injury from that block
and and I think the committee has to
look at this and say let's just make
this like illegal blocks below the waist
let's make this rule only applicable
during change of possession plays after
a change a possession or during kick
plays and that's when the D cleaners
happen not when it's a running
that's almost in close line play
technically technically the way the rule
is set up yeah it is a foul but
technically there are a lot of things on
the field that are fouls but aren't
called I mean look the tackles sometimes
they're so far off the line of scrimmage
but they don't call that because for one
thing they want to give the tackles a
little bit of an edge when they're
trying to block the speed rusher so the
quarterback doesn't get hit too often so
to me I just don't think that was a call
that needed to be made and another rule
that I think was brought in that all of
a sudden serious unintended consequences
have have begun to appear well by rule
DeAndre Carter's flipping of the ball to
Tony currenty in that game to kick off
the second half of the game was a ball
that just flipped and lucid which is why
karani backed off and ruled it a
touchdown and fumbled to begin the
second half and then common sense rules
are applied on walk me through how that
worked out just so there are other
officials as we know from the department
that are on the sidelines that stepped
in to Tony and said hey let's be common
sense here and rule that a touchback
because he had no intention of clearly
running it out Mike yeah and you know
and I listen there's a lot of people
that have communication the four
alternates that are on the field and
let's remember that New York is dialed
in to the four alternates on the
sidelines and the seven officials on the
field
look there are interpretations it's not
in the rulebook and the interpretation
has always been when a player deuce does
something stupid like that he's given up
his right he's given up his ability to
advance and and it really it came in in
a couple different forms where you're
more likely to see it is when you know
at the end of a game a defender
intercepts a pass in the end zone and he
goes to the ground and he pops up and he
spikes the ball well he was never
touched
and he intercepted the pass and his
opponents in zone so the ball is still
alive so technically he gave up the ball
but that's you know we said you know he
declares himself down
by doing that and and that's we've had
that interpretation in for a long time
we said you know if you flicked the ball
to the official in the endzone or
whatever it might be and he catches it
you're gonna leave that as a live ball
oh my god the poor official okay let's
got to play through it go get the ball
the official gets to gets trampled the
disappointing thing is that Toni reacted
the way he did I mean he he don't was
the interpretation and he knows for a
number of reasons like the signal that
was given that says hey I'm not going to
advance this ball normally you let it
hit in the end zone but when he flicks
it to Toni and reaches over to pick up
his time common sense dictates that he
has given himself up and kudos to
whoever went out there and got to Toni
whether it was New York through the
alternates or the alternates themselves
to to get that corrected because you
know as Dean said at one point not
everything is in the rulebook if you put
everything in the rulebook my god the
thing would be 600 pages long instead of
200 but that's an interpretation that
has been in there for a long time and
and and at least they did get it
corrected the last two minutes I have
with you the cat and mouse between
variable and Bella check with
purposefully moving players before spree
stood create pre-snap penalties that
would wine the clock the actual play
clock down is a a total loophole that I
think Bella check was the one who first
found and Exploited it earlier in the
season they're able used it against him
was is this legal and is this something
that is going to be closed do you think
by the competition committee if it is
legal right now yeah I think it will I
think it'll be closed and I was more
amused by Bill Belichick being mad at
the officials you know for one of his
former coaches and players doing the
same thing that he did back in October
since then it's been done twice by
variable now it's been done by John
Harbaugh though this is a copycat league
and so when when they when Bill figured
out this loophole then you know teams
have copied that but I
they'll find a way to do it you know I
like the college rule for example that
if you're in punt formation and you get
a delay of game in punt formation the
clock automatically stays stop it though
you don't rewind it so there there are
some ways to clean it up and they
complicate it by saying you know the
delay they took a delay from punt
formation and then they took then they
purposely fault started I would suspect
if that happens again after they kind of
closed the loophole that it'll be
unsportsmanlike conduct the second time
it happens and not the third which is
basically the way that the you interpret
the rule now but yeah it's it's clearly
a loophole then don't think as we go
further on into the playoffs if a team
is ahead and you're at that seven minute
mark of the fourth quarter and it's your
advantage to run time off the clock you
basically have the ability to run one
minute and forty-five seconds which is
what happened when brave will did it
you've got that ability to do that Mike
love the time always appreciate it enjoy
going to Lambeau and we'll chat down the
line okay you got a man right back at
you that's Mike Pereira at Mike Pereira
on Twitter for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR Live or download
the Rich Eisen show app